hello and welcome to this video playing
I am tich tich rock Tetrarch something
is that actually no name Queens gambit
you should eat okay I'm completely
convinced that the only way forward for
white and in this line is to them play
c5
these this kind of positions are at best
a microscopic advantage for wide but
quite often I deserve fairly simple
affair from black to I get get to equal
play you should be five here maybe it's
not such a nice thing that Bishop is
potentially hanging after Bishop f6
takes Queen takes but okay this is a
stupid move it's good Bishop b5 this one
okay
interesting this is the stock right okay
for white it's got lots of minor pieces
traded and this is what you usually want
to do in the iqp position now if you
play against the iqp you usually want to
trade the minor pieces and keep the and
keep the rooks Queen and so on on the
board 94 this Queen f3
and it's a lift from a king I think
hmm yeah why does it pull here maybe I
can take do this yeah this could be okay
96 now should be all right no actually I
just got some knowing moves here hi that
wasn't so good so in person yeah it's
certainly problematic here
okay anyway what is he doing then g3 on
some threatening well threatening is a
strong word but checking Queen d6 yeah
this movie moving the locusts plundering
and mayhem this is the problem
and check king of cephalus also bloody
awful food
not a happy move check
maybe just Queen c7
queen of eight and potentially checking
here
you
yeah just awful just awful check
yeah what a terrible game by black check
play that far too superficially
check black resign lets you have to end
this session i'm just playing too
exhausted i think anyway so yeah it was
kind of a very quality oriented line but
I didn't get it him it was always a
little bit worse and night is sexy i was
a very bad decision of course why this
better but after this i'm basically lost
i think this is just terrible yeah i
think i actually actually made some
mistakes in and happy i did i did i
tried the same that it's been a while
since I've played this line and I think
probably I should do this when I analyze
this I had found out that the bishop
should go here then night is 6 and so on
this is better than Bishop g4 but ok I
played it very quickly in the game and
him this is not so easy one problem is
that i don't have this move because he
can take this is attacked well i really
would like to play with your f6 and now
i am already an under some pressure it's
not funny at all and this is kind of
understand it's not cord what can i do
is here i'm suffering yes he has managed
to trade too many minor pieces and the
d5 point is just a weakness yeah not a
good game i'm just not a good game
here and this is just just unplayable
position like I cannot I cannot tour
this problem my king position is too
weak and it's got the seventh-ranked the
engine wants to play great oops this
great line why just place whatever and
win Wow terribly bad okay thanks for
watching